right now it's all about outstanding
brunches I love brunch it's a great way
of relaxing with friends and family not
taking yourself or anything else too
seriously and brunch dishes should
reflect that spicy sweet or savory
anything goes and one of our all-time
favorites a dish that always creates a
stir is the daddy of all brunches steak
sandwiches for me the secret of a great
brunch is fun and casual fuss free
cooking and everyone helping themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich you
want the rolls-royce of beef it has to
be Philip now seasoned it beautifully I
like to open up the top of the pepper
mill to increase the size of the pepper
in the steak so it gives that bit of
heat nice little chunks you just roll
now nicely all the way around now slice
the garlic in half pan nice and hot
olive oil in hold the steak and just
place it into the pan don't drop it
at the front of the pan
we're still the patent forward cook the
back of the stage dual purpose now roll
it back and stare underneath next my
garlic and roast that garlic thyme fry
that time I want to hear it
we're not looking for a lot of color
because you're gonna dry out and fill it
so just one end turn it back down and
clear the other ending lift up your time
place it on top of the garlic
lift up your fill it and sit that on top
of your garlic butter in take a spoon
tilt the pan gently lift up and bake
but that's scented garlic it's fine
flavor the steaks gonna cook evenly
cuz it's sound a little a little bear in
the oven 8 to 10 minutes
[Music]
panel for the relish you think of a
steak sandwich you think of a sort of
nice heated tomato relish to make the
relish finely diced a red onion a finger
rule one in front two behind through and
chopped Wow
next roughly chop a Chile keeping the
seeds in for extra heat start off with
the olive oil into a pan onion
generous with the olive oil a nice sort
of rich silky relish from there taken
artists you can't just use red tomatoes
but these yellow and red make a perfect
combination now cut your salt in those
Martha go take a wooden spoon and just
sort of break them up once the skins
blister the whole tomato just starts to
release all that really nice sweet
texture look teaspoon show vinegar gives
that nice acidic balance the sweetness
of its martyrs turn down the gas and
just let them sort of stew perfectly now
a steak sandwich would not be complete
unless it had the most amazing mustard
mayonnaise simply add three tablespoons
of mayonnaise to three teaspoons of
whole-grain mustard
[Music]
now I've got the relish source down to
like a really nice Jam now I want to
make that relation litte bit more
fragrant some basil slice it through
spring clamp as line there
[Music]
peaceful look at this and she is my
crown jewels time to take it out
smell is incredible just based one more
time for
touch is quite soft in the center so
it's just coming up to mid-rare let it
rest at the same time you cooked it
it'll be nice and pink evenly throughout
the state to make my sandwich I'm gonna
char grill some sliced G patter bread
seasoned it nicely just a little drizzle
of olive oil I want to get that bread
nice and crispy pan nice and hot Brett
in push it down smell is amazing that
char sort of charcoal flavor you got
those marks on the bread it's just stops
the bread from becoming soggy and look
at this here it is stunning on slice it
gently
one beautiful slice
well it's nice and pink all the way
through and the beef is so soft it's
almost like slicing through butter the
knife do the work take a little bit of
mayonnaise spread that the back of the
spoon on both sides next lettuce take
that beautiful slice of beef well and
then relish on top of that beef and just
slice a sandwich in half eat now that's
what I call a steak sandwich
trust me sir the sublime sandwich for
brunch and you would have smile on
everyone's face
[Music]
next up my guide to buying the best beef
and steaks if you want the ultimate
brunch you can't do any better than
start with a perfect steak and one man
who really knows his steak is master
butcher Danny Ludgate steak is my
favorite type of meat and I think it's
really good to enjoy different varieties
of steak when choosing a steak that you
want you need to look at exactly what
you want out of it
from my ultimate steak sandwich I used
to fill it because it's the most tender
the fill it does least amount of work
than all other muscles is tucked away in
the rib cage this means that when you
find a fill it's it's incredibly soft
like butter it's the most expensive or
you get what you pay for
there's a wide array of cuts to choose
from all different in taste and texture
if in doubt ask your butcher this would
be the rump section where the rub comes
from which is basically the backsides
take the bone out and what you're left
with is a wonderful State rump steak
characteristically a little bit tougher
than the sirloin or little bit chewing
in the ribeye but a really strong flavor
for the steak again when flying run look
for the marbling try and get some fat
covering on the steak you can always cut
it off after it's cooked rumps one of
the best value steaks I love it thinly
cut and flash-fried in stir fries or
simply marinated and wait on the
barbecue another great value but
delicious cut is the hanger steak known
as the butcher's cut because they often
keep it for themselves it's great
marinated and cooked quickly
move the sirloin which is basically the
back of the animal a nicer lon like this
really well marbled don't fly too lean
so once the solo is trimmed up it looks
something like this not too much fat but
you need a little bit of cooking it next
to the sirloin is the ribbon really
popular now and rib eyes small nice
really tender juicy steaks really
especially good for barbecuing or
grilling fantastic probably my favorite
steak Revere ribeye ribeye is especially
delicious because the marbling in the
meat loads it with flavor for full-on
steak experience try the t-bone steak
with a small tender finish steak on one
side of the bone and a larger flavor
some sirloin on the other take your
butchers advice and you won't go wrong
the final word have to go to Danny when
buying meat knowledge really is power so
it's important to ask as many questions
about the meat you're buying find out
the breeds how its aged and decide
exactly what you want to do a particular
job that should then give you a really
amazing end product
[Music]
the great thing about brunch is there
are no rules the only thing I insist on
are it's got to be fuss free easy to
cook and so delicious it puts you in a
good mood for the rest of the day
and for me pancakes always hit the spot
here are three of my deliciously
different recipes certified to liven up
your morning's first up fluffy blueberry
and ricotta pancakes with yogurt
[Music]
star by adding 125 grams of plain flour
a teaspoon of baking powder a pinch of
salt a tablespoon of sugar then create a
wet in the center separate two eggs and
add the yolks keeping the whites for
later beat the yolks into the flour
pouring in milk gradually to form a
smooth batter
[Music]
next fold in 125 grams of creamy ricotta
cheese and 100 grams of fresh
blueberries
now with your egg whites until they
almost reach soft peaks
then gently folding to the pancakemix
keeping in the air to make sure the
pancakes are extra light and really
fluffy and olive oil and butter into a
hot pan and spoon in the mix to make
small pancakes cooking into a golden
brown on both sides
to finish top with Greek yogurts fresh
blueberries and drizzle over lovely
runny honey sweet savory fruity and
delicious made in 15 minutes
perfect brunch pancakes my second simple
pancake brunch recipe is succulent crab
and mascarpone crepes
[Music]
for the filly put cooked white crab meat
into a bowl add in mascarpone the zest
and juice of a lemon finely chopped
chives and for a spicy hit KN pepper
stir and set aside for the pancake
batter simply add flour salt an egg and
milk then whisk into a smooth mixture
add oil to a hot non-stick pan ladle in
batter to cover the bottom and swirl
around spreading out nice and thinly
when lovely and golden flip over turn
out and spoon the delicious crab mix
into the center of the pancake and roll
finally sprinkle with some chopped
chives and devour
my second pancake recipe crabber
masculine crepes a fantastic easy brunch
cooked in minutes
[Music]
when you want your pancakes sweet and
zingy this recipe is perfect
coconut pancakes with mango and lime
syrup
for the lime syrup simply add water
castor sugar the zest and juice of a
lime and simmer for 10 minutes
to make the easy pancake batter put
flour baking powder and desiccated
coconut into a bowl then crack in an egg
add coconut milk and whisk into the
batter into well combined
sweeten with runny honey
now you're ready to fry add melted
butter to a hot pan place in heat
teaspoons of batter flip and cook until
golden for a lovely vibrant wake up sir
with sliced fresh mango and drill over
the gorgeous citrusy syrup sweet sticky
and utterly irresistible ready in under
20 minutes
the ultimate indulgent pancakes
[Music]
faster prepare easy to make three
effortless recipes guaranteed to bring
some sparkle to your brunches okay
here's my guide to the best kitchen
equipment everything you need to know
about the basic kit that will get you
cooking fantastic food chopping boards
for brunch one of the most useful things
is a great chopping board get the right
one and it'll be your friend for life I
prefer heavy duty one because there's so
much more durable they can be flipped
over the minute you want to go from
vegetables
it's a prepping official means always
keep it with Jake off underneath that
actually stops the board from sliding
careful you wooden board by rubbing it
with oil every so often any cooking oil
will do wooden boards for me always the
best easy to clean and long-lasting when
you do wash your wooden board you never
let it stand in water or put it in the
dishwasher as it may split by the best
you can afford and take good care of it
for brunch I'd love something sweet and
have always been a fan of classic
British crumpets with butter and jam but
once you try cooking them at home you'll
never want to buy them from shops again
this is another great recipe you can
stake your life on
it's my homemade crumpet whether you're
cooking for two three or even a gang
some of the best brunch dishes are
always the simplest these crumpets are
absolutely delicious and it's a great
end to a fantastic brunch first off
we're gonna make the mix what do you
think of growing up the smell and the
taste of amazing crumpet and never
leaves you to make the mix the secret is
that when your milk up the bull but do
not boil it the minute it boils turn it
off and let it sit there now flour in a
nice pinch of salt in now add half a
teaspoon of bicarb that gives it
aeration and really lifts the mixture up
all those lovely little holes a nice
pinch of sugar and then a teaspoon of
yeast dry yeast
now once the Mills balled turn it off
and add some warm water about 10
tablespoons 150 mil that cools down the
milk but more importantly it doesn't
destroy the yeast half of the milk in
first stop and give that a really good
mix now the rest of it
you can just see that there's no lumps
through there as it drips through the
whisk now we're looking for it to double
in size and get nice and light so pop in
the warm place whilst you get on with a
delicious topping beautiful strawberries
but caramelize almost like a very quick
strawberry jam panel just slice these in
half
some sugar a couple of tablespoons we're
gonna take the sugar to a nice light
camera it's just starting to change
color now turn the gas down and whether
I have the strawberries beautiful it's
sweating the strawberries down quickly
and the caramels breaking down in a
wonderful glaze on the strawberries some
lemon grated into the strawberries gives
it that kind of freshness that really
starts to break down the strawberries
nice guess up smells incredible some
lemon juice such as balsamic vinegar
and that gives it a really nice
delicious tartness now off she goes as
the strawberries start to cool down and
one naturally thicken them set
beautifully now for the crumpet some
ways doubled in size but you're very
careful you don't knock the ball because
it can sort of push out all that air
this areata dis nicest lights just see
texture she's ready to go
did you boil it
in Riga instead of making normal small
crumpets I'm making a giant one ideal
for sharing now turn the gas down and
just start to see a traditional crumpet
style cooking process we want those nice
tiny little holes on top and then crispy
crunchy base right now it's time to add
the butter just slide the butter down
the back
that gives it a really nice nutty flavor
at the end fish nice flip useful take
that out
the job
the secret for the juicers would have
run inside all those little holes think
about tartness of the balsamic vinegar
the strawberries beautifully soft and
almost pureed wrapped and the delicious
can now finish that with a nice ball of
creme fraiche let that sit there and
that is an amazing way of finishing off
a traditional brunch with something
sweet something delicious and something
you're dying to tuck into
[Music]
next my tricks the trade and kitchen
tips
fruit can be a great healthy option for
brunch and knowing how to get the best
out of it can make all the difference
first up how to peel and cut a mango the
easy way
homie you stalk end up cut either side
of the stone cut all the way into the
flesh making squares without cutting
through the skin then turn it inside out
and carefully cut your pieces off
a great tip to check if a pineapple is
ripe is to pull a leaf out from the top
if it comes away easily
it's ripe and ready for slicing my tip
to get the flesh out of a Kiwi is to
simply cut the fruit in half and scoop
out with a teaspoon try it
it really works if you have fruit that's
not perfectly ripe the tip is to put a
banana in a paper bag then add your
unripe fruit put it in a dark place and
the banana will speed up the ripening
process of the other fruit you can make
a grapefruit puree to company a brunch
pancake or a crumpet in a blender to
clean it afterwards add a cup of warm
water and run the machine for a few
seconds empty out then simply repeat
with a drop of washing-up liquid then
rinse
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons top tips
and 100 recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the App Store for details go on get
cooking